chris cuomo finally realizes that
covering his brother andrew for cnn is a
bad idea
dr seuss is canceled in virginia and joe
biden pursues reparations i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let big tech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing
expressvpn.com
ben as i'm speaking about the fact is
you can't trust the big tech bros with
your information they don't like you
very much
in fact there's a wide variety of
institutions all seeking your data and
then want to use that data to monetize
and simultaneously use the data against
you instead why don't you just hide your
data it is your data
as private entities tech companies can
operate pretty much as they choose
protect your personal data from big tech
with the vpn i trust for my online
protection
expressvpn when i use expressvpn my
connection gets rebooted through their
secure encrypted servers so these
companies can't see my ip address at all
my internet activity becomes anonymized
my network data is encrypted
i recommend expressvpn to anyone who
uses the internet so you know
everyone the best part you don't need to
be tech savvy at all to use
expressivevpn you just download the app
on your phone or computer you tap one
button
and now you are protected so protect
your internet activity with the vpn i
use
every single day visit get three extra
months free
on a one-year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com to get three extra
months for free
expressvpn.com to learn more go check
them out right now
expressvpn.com and get started
protecting your data it is after all
your data i'm gonna go to expressvpn.com
you get three extra months free
on that one year package okay so andrew
cuomo continues to be
under fire for basically being
really creepy and a weirdo and if he did
any of this stuff in the private sector
he would be fired
tomorrow so the latest story to break
about
andrew cuomo frankly this is the least
disturbing of the story so we had a
couple of stories already one was from
a person named lindsay boylan who worked
with cuomo she suggested basically
he called her up to his office for the
express purpose of trying to kiss her
and then he gave her an unwanted kiss
we've had people suggest that he has
harassed them in the past make
lewd comments to them a 25 year old
woman came forward and said that while
she was working for him he asked
questions about whether she had sex with
older men and whether she had a
stamp and this kind of stuff
okay well this particular story is the
third in a line this is from
the new york times anna rouch had never
met governor andrew cuomo before
encountering him at a crowded new york
city wedding reception in september
2019.
her first impression was positive enough
the governor was working the room after
toasting the newlyweds and when he came
upon it miss rooch now 33 she thanked
him for his kind words about her friends
but what happened next instantly
unsettled her mr cuomo put his hand on
ms rooch's bare lower back she said in
an interview
on monday when she removed his hand with
her own mrs rich recalled the governor
remarked that she seemed aggressive
and placed his hands on her cheeks he
asked if he could kiss her loudly enough
for a friend standing nearby to hear
the search was bewildered by the
entreaty she said and pulled away as the
governor drew closer
she said i was so confused and shocked
and embarrassed i turned my head away
and i didn't have
words in the moment this account comes
after two former aides accused cuomo of
sexual harassment in the workplace
plunging his third term into turmoil as
the governor's defenders and cuomo
himself
strained to explain his behavior he put
out a statement suggesting
that this was um misinterpreted as an
unwanted flirtation
since the sense anyone felt that way i'm
truly sorry about that now here's the
weird thing um all of this
is caught on picture and um
first of all for andrew cuomo not a
great picture
so being lit like directly like satan is
a little bit on the nose
i feel like here he looks like he's
completely red like whatever the
lighting here is
uh it's a problem for him and this woman
has on her face the same exact
expression as peloton lady
right it looks as though andrew cuomo is
about to perform the scene from the dark
knight
in which the joker asks maggie gallagher
if she wants to know how he got that
smile
it's very weird like very very weird now
there are gradations of behavior that
are
you know the end of your career the
gradations of the behavior
range from you know harvey weinstein
like actually rape people to
an unwanted kiss two he asked her and
she said no and then you let go
of her head now number one as the
practicing orthodox jew in your life let
me tell you you shouldn't be touching
people without their permission like
ever
okay that is also the moral thing to do
i am not somebody who does this
in fact i've been mocked in the past for
doing the keanu reeves hover hand in
pictures
right i don't want to touch people
without their permission and so in long
rope lines of people where i'm taking
pictures with people you'll very often
see my hand kind of above their shoulder
because i don't really want to touch
people right it's not not really a thing
and i think frankly that politicians and
public figures should engage in the
keanu reeves hover hand he's sort of
famous for this
uh andrew cuomo is not just a hugger
he's a kisser apparently or
and he um and he goes directly in for
grabbing this lady by the head
which is a very aggressive and weird
move now is that the kind of thing that
a governor should lose his gubernatorial
seat over should he be impeached over
that
i mean typically speaking i would say no
i'd say that this is bad behavior
bad behavior there are gradations of bad
behavior and him making weird comments
to women
about eating the whole sausage making
like lewd suggestions or
weird jokes like that that does not seem
to me this kind of behavior
you lose your gubernatorial seed over
however however andrew cuomo has set a
standard
and andrew cuomo's standard is that
there is no due process andrew cuomo's
standard
is the me to believe all women's
standard and if you set yourself up
as a backer of that standard you deserve
everything you get when that movement
comes for you because the
revolutionaries
have no friends they have only obstacles
and when andrew cuomo became an obstacle
andrew cuomo is in serious trouble right
now because there's every major
politician in new york
all of them have their long knives out
for this guy they hate him okay here's
the reality they hate andrew cuomo he's
a jackass
everybody in new york knows this if
you're a new york democrat you know that
andrew cuomo is a jackass
and any opportunity to get rid of him is
the opportunity to get rid of him right
now a year ago all this stuff would have
come out
everybody would have ignored it a year
ago he was very useful as a tool against
donald trump but now donald trump is no
longer
president and that means that andrew
cuomo he got to go
right it's perfectly convenient to get
rid of andrew cuomo because at the same
time you're getting rid of a guy that
nobody really likes very much because
he's very aggressive and very nasty and
he's a jerk to everybody
and also you're clearing the way for the
letitia james's of the world and the
aocs of the world and that's something
that the democratic party would like to
do frankly
not only that you also get to
quote-unquote re-establish the standard
that you care about me too because one
of the things you may have noticed about
the metoo moment
is that it has wavered in its strength
and consistency
at the very beginning it was like well
you know harvey weinstein is real bad
and if he's a democrat so be it he's
still got to go
and then it started to waver just a
little bit right if it was tara reid
accusing joe biden of something well
then we just sort of black out those
accusations they don't matter very much
in other words me too is a standard that
is subjected
to the importance of politics you'll
notice for example that the democratic
party tossed al franken off the back of
the bus
and then back the bus up over him why
did they do that they did that because
they were in the middle of a race in
alabama in which roy moore was running
roy moore was the
senate candidate in alabama who had been
accused of trolling the food court for
14 year old girls like 30 years ago
and so the democratic party wanted to
set a standard and the standard of the
democratic party wanted to set was at
least we're not those guys and that was
when all of the al franken stuff came
out you know the pictures of him
hovering over
the uh the breasts of a sleeping woman
and making some sort of
weird funny pose over it and so al
franken lost his job in the senate over
that and five minutes later they were
like oh that was a mistake because they
thought roy moore was going to win in
alabama and then they would be able to
hang that around the neck of the
of the republicans like an albatross for
the rest of time it turns out roy moore
lost and then like oh we shouldn't have
got rid of al franken so here's the
thing
politics is always the name of the game
here andrew cuomo is going down right
now
not because of any of this he's going
down because of the nursing home scandal
but
they can't say it's because of the
nursing home scandal because that then
that would be to admit that they should
have known
all along it would be to admit that they
blew this story from the very beginning
they would have to admit that their
approach to covet has been dead wrong
the entire
time because if it turns out that andrew
cuomo's real sin here is not his
behavior with women yes that's sinful
and yes it's gross and it's yucky but
that
in and of itself would not get him
canceled right the only thing that would
really truly justifiably get andrew
cuomo kicked out of office
would be him covering up the fact that
his policies led directly to the deaths
of elderly people in nursing homes
they can't but they can't admit that
because then that would be to admit that
because we all knew that see here's the
thing
we all knew in the middle of last year
that andrew cuomo had
had been participating in cover-ups
in new york we knew that his nursing
home policy was garbage and we knew
more than anything else that his nursing
home policy stood in direct contrast to
the nursing home policy of the person
that the left hated most in terms of
governors ron desantis in florida
right desantis had protected the nursing
homes and then told everybody else you
know what you got to live like free
americans
make your own decisions and guess what
right now new york is ranked number two
in deaths per million and is seeing an
uptick in cases by the way and florida
we're doing just fine
right florida is ranked like number 27
with the second oldest population in
america after maine which really means
the oldest population in america because
maine has seven people in a moose
right so the reality here is that the
media have decided to cover the andrew
cuomo sex
stuff because they don't want to cover
the andrew cuomo nursing home stuff
the actual scandal so instead they will
make it about look at look at how honest
we are right we're so honest
and now we're covering this stuff right
i mean we couldn't have covered it last
year this is what chris chaliza cnn said
we couldn't have covered this last year
we didn't know about this stuff last
year
right how would we have known that he
was sexually harassing the help
by the way there are a bunch of great
tweets over the course of the last
couple of years about the love gov that
are coming back to haunt people now
remember that for the last year or so
the establishment media decided that
andrew cuomo was a sex symbol
that he was the one that all the ladies
wanted to be with
i mean my my personal favorite tweet in
all of us was katie hill
the disgraced calif former congress
california congresswoman who was
stopping half her staff
she had the whole thing about like how
she was attracted to andrew cuomo i was
like well yeah you could see that one
coming couldn't you but
again there's a reason that the media
have decided to cover this right now and
what you're seeing
is that when conservatives complain
about media coverage of cuomo
the media will say two things one we
didn't know about any of the sex stuff a
year ago and now we do know about it so
we're honest guys we're objective don't
you see
we're doing the journalism that you guys
should should
how could you criticize our journalism
when we're the ones covering the story
because
this story is not actually the super
important story the sex stuff okay like
it's important
and there should be an investigation and
it's bad
the the behavior of the andrew cuomo in
again there are gradations to each of
these incidents like calling a woman up
to your office who works for you so you
can kiss her it's bad behavior
and maybe fireable behavior going up to
a woman at a wedding and asking if you
can kiss her is not actually fireable
behavior
grabbing her head is a different sort
right there are gradations to all this
stuff but there is one thing
that not only should andrew cuomo have
been tossed out of office for he should
have been tossed out of office
last year for it because we all knew
about it back in may which is that he
was lying about his nursing home stats
and that his policies in nursing homes
had gotten a lot of people killed and by
the way it is amazing that the media
ever chose andrew cuomo as their guy
why because very early on in the
pandemic you will remember andrew cuomo
shut down the state
very late very late if you go back to
his comments in early march they sound
exactly like trump's comments in early
march
it was only later in march that andrew
cuomo started to be like the lockdown
gov
so again everything being about politics
and nothing being about truth is
a very simple rule to watch in action
and you can see it most of all when it
comes to the
media coverage from his bro from i will
never say he's fredo because i've heard
from chris cuomo that it is
somehow racist to call him fredo like
the dumber brother from
the godfather i don't know hell he he
said it was like
using the n-word which is a weird take
but in any case
not fredo over here right chris cuomo he
was doing for a year
for a long year a comedy smothers
brother's routine
with his bro he was doing this routine
where he'd bring him on and he have a
giant q-tip
and my brother is the the greatest
governor in america i'm so proud of him
he's just amazing
chris cuomo was doing this for a year
and cnn not only let them cover it this
way
they they promoted it it was look at
chris cuomo interviewed his own brother
now there were those of us who said um
isn't it a conflict of interest that
you're covering your own brother like
isn't that just a little bit of a
conflict
i mean this is a time when news is kind
of important and we want to know what
the best policies are and we
want to know about his actual
performance as governor and instead
we're getting
mom liked you best routines from chris
and andrew and well now now
is chris cuomo going to cover the fact
that his brother is enmeshed
in the sexual harassment scandal no
don't be silly
that would be a conflict of interest you
see see here's the thing it's not a
conflict of interest when you're
praising your brother it's a conflict of
interest when you would have to
criticize your brother so here is chris
cuomo
last night saying i can't cover any of
this it's a conflict of interest
his journalism comes out again
obviously i'm aware of what's going on
with my brother
and obviously i cannot cover it because
he is my brother now of course
cnn has to cover it they have covered it
extensively
and they will continue to do so
i have always cared very deeply
about these issues and profoundly so
i just wanted to tell you that there's a
lot of news going on that matters
also so let's get after
that oh my god like the fact that cnn
thinks they can get away with this i
mean he liter
i'm gonna repeat the words very slowly
for those of you
who continue to think andrew cuomo is a
good governor and vote for democrats
thinking that they actually care about
you
i'm gonna repeat this very slowly for
you guys okay quote obviously i cannot
cover it because he is my brother
direct quote from chris cuomo about his
brother andrew immediate sex scandal
um obviously i cannot cover it because
he is my brother
so question were they brothers last year
i seem to remember them being brothers
last year in fact i believed that they
were brothers
since their youth i i don't think they
recently became
brothers like in the last couple weeks
or so and was andrew cuomo kind of
relevant to the political conversation
at any point in here
i feel like probably he was was he not i
mean they were literally talking about
replacing joe biden on the ticket with
andrew cuomo if biden should falter so i
feel like it was kind of relevant
but here's the thing about our media
they don't give two dams
about the truth they don't care okay
they don't
all it is about for them is the
narrative the narrative last year is
that andrew cuomo was good and donald
trump was bad
and now the narrative is that andrew
cuomo is bad and therefore
we have to as a matter of journalistic
objectivity not allow
chris to cover his brother amazing
amazing stuff
and let me just say this when it comes
to the rest of the cnn crew over there
they are all chris cuomo when it comes
to the democratic party
as chris cuomo is to andrew cuomo so cnn
is to the democratic party they're
brothers in arms they agree with the
agenda
they're sycophants and they're covering
the people that they love
that is the reality of the situation
which is why you shouldn't trust their
takes on a lot of these particular
issues
okay in just a second we're gonna get to
the continuation of the fragmentation
of our culture and i wanna talk a little
bit about what's gonna go down over the
next week or so because next week the
trial of derek shalvin
in the alleged murder of george floyd is
going to begin so we'll get to what is
going on in minnesota it's getting spicy
over there
first spring is springing and it's the
perfect reminder to tidy up and get your
life in order why not start by
protecting your family with life
insurance
policy genius can help you compare top
insurers in one place and save 50
or more in the process once you find
your best option the policy genius team
will set up your new policy for you
and answer any questions you have along
the way here's how you can get started
first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need
and compare quotes to find your best
price policy genius makes it easy to
compare policies from as little as 15
bucks a month you might even be eligible
to skip that in-person medical exam
since their licensed agents work for you
not the insurance companies there is
zero hassle if you hit any speed bumps
during the application process
policy genius will take care of
everything that kind of service has
earned policy genius a five-star rating
across thousands of reviews on
trustpilot and google the best part
all the benefits of policy genius the
comparison tool the handling of
paperwork the unbiased advice
totally free to use so while you are
tidying up around the house this spring
why not get your life insurance
organized as well
it could save 50 or more by comparing
quotes feel good knowing that if
something happens your loved ones
will be taken care of go to
policygenius.com to get started policy
genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and quite important to get it
right okay so
over in minneapolis all hell is about to
break loose over the next
couple of weeks according to the daily
wire scale reporting
the minneapolis courthouse that will
feature the trial connected to george
floyd who died while in police custody
on may
25th 2020 has been quote turned into a
veritable fortress according to the new
york post
jury selection begins on march 8th for
the trial that is where derek schauvin
is charged with murdering floyd
the post reports that hennepin county
district court has quote been ringed
with concrete barriers security fencing
and barbed wire
this is in addition to increased
security in the area including
minneapolis police hennepin county
sheriff's deputies many
minneapolis state troopers minnesota
state troopers and the national guard
minnesota public safety commissioner
john harrington said we're not going to
be caught flat-footed
apparently the post reported that
minneapolis authorities have been
hatching security plans for the trial
since july
when outrage over floyd's death on may
25th while in police custody sparked
massive protests worldwide
minnesota governor tim walls a democrat
sought to assure residents saying
there's going to be very high emotion on
all sides of this
and we will be prepared apparently
according to the mayor of minneapolis
as many as 3 000 law enforcement
personnel could be deployed before the
case
goes to a jury it's not just the
courthouse that's being prepared for
unrest the city jail city hall
also being reinforced with fencing
barbed wire and barriers
also the city of minneapolis they just
backed off of a plan they had their
actual plan to hire social media
influencers to combat misinformation
during the derek shaven trial the reason
for this of course
is because we have seen many instances
over the past year in which there will
be rumors that go around about a
particular incident involving police
that are just not true
and people then riot based on those
rumors so we have seen that many times
over the course of the last year where
there will be
a text that goes out that somebody was
shot unarmed and it turns out not only
were they not unarmed they were
threatening the police
but a riot starts anyway because the
facts do not matter in these particular
cases now the reason i bring this up
is because it is a very bad situation
eric we are in a very bad situation in
our country
when only a verdict that a particular
side of the political alex results in
peace
right in other words if derek shalvin
gets convicted of second-degree murder
which i think is an overcharge legally
speaking
this looks more like third degree murder
to me if that at all right
like there's a better case for excessive
force than either of those two frankly
i think that chalvin has a fairly strong
defense here i mean just on a legal
level put aside the morality
of what derek schalvin did chalvin on a
legal level is going to have a fairly
strong defense here
and i'm just warning people about this
right now because the way the media are
going to portray this is if derek calvin
gets off then it's going to be
because the the system failed and your
eyes are
yeah you can trust your eyes when you
watch that tape but you can't trust the
system
derek shalvin's defense is pretty
straight forward here his defense is
going to be that george floyd had enough
fentanyl in him to kill horse okay that
is gonna be his his claim
and there's gonna be fairly good
evidence for that there was a medical
autopsy done after george floyd died
the medical examiner said explicitly
that if george floyd had been found dead
in his house with that level of fentanyl
in his blood
then he would have immediately declared
it a drug overdose
the the medical examiner in that
particular case
struggled to find evidence that the that
the
knee on the neck of george floyd is what
actually caused his death
there's good video evidence from before
the actual eight minute clip that
everybody has seen
that george floyd was acting in
extraordinarily erratic ways that he was
resisting arrest
that he appeared to be suffering from a
condition that is known in the police
community as excited delirium
where people are high on drugs and then
their heart rate starts to rise ex
extremely fast they start to act very
very erratic
and then if they have underlying health
conditions in any way then
very you know in in certain instances
they die of that
underlying health condition the
minneapolis statutes
with regard to police use of force do
allow the kind of hold
that chalvin was using on george floyd
george floyd explicitly asked not to be
put in the car
they tried to push george floyd into the
car he said he wanted the windows open
they opened the windows for him
he then pushed his way out of the car
and then he said he wanted to be outside
the car
at which point they held him down and
again just medically speaking if
somebody says that they cannot breathe
if you can say that you can't breathe
that typically means that you can
actually breathe
right what that means medically speaking
is that you're having a heart condition
right very often when someone says they
can't breathe
that is not because you were having a
stroke a closure of the trachea all
right
it's not it's not about your your neck
being in some way pressured right
there's no damage that was actually done
to george floyd's neck in the autopsy so
again all of this is going to be what
the defense is for derrick schalvin
and they have to prove some level of
intent by shoving which is going to be
super difficult
right the the notion that you can that
you can say that this police officer
came to kill that day and which is kind
of what you have to say in a second
degree murder trial first agreed like he
fully intended to kill him he wanted to
do it
second degree is reckless disregard that
he did it
knowing that george floyd might die
that's going to be hard to prove
again if they really wanted to get
shalvin the best they could have done
here i think is probably an excessive
force charge
now maybe because of all the hub up
surrounding the trial the jury decides
to convict anyway because they don't
want to be the people who are known as
letting derrick chalvin off the hook
for what is the most celebrated case of
alleged police brutality in our lifetime
at least since rodney king but the but
still
the defense here is going to be pretty
strong and i'm giving that warning right
now because what you're going to see for
the next several weeks
is that there will be justifications for
riots put forth on all sides that is a
foregone conclusion derek schalvin
should be convicted of second-degree
murder no matter the evidence the jury
will
if the jury does not vote to convict
chalvin then the
the call will go forth that the american
justice system
is incredibly unjust and that george
floyd did not receive the due process
of the law in in terms of his
victimization and in terms of the
treatment of the supposed perpetrator
and then there will be riots and that is
why they are putting up the fencing
right now
right it was used as an indicator of the
ill will of many on the right when we
had to fence off the capitol building in
the aftermath of january 6th
it should be used as an indicator that
people are not going to care about the
fact they're not going to care about the
process here
if you're putting up the fences
preliminarily in a trial
right that is not a good sign for the
country but that is the country that we
now reside in
and this is sort of the point we now
live in a fragmented reality in which
the facts don't matter
i'm perfectly willing to evaluate the
facts on derrick shalvin as they come
out
in the derrick shavon trial right we're
going to know more about that in the
same way i am perfectly willing
to look at the facts of each individual
case because i think that the facts
matter
and when it's ahmed ah berry that looks
a lot like a racist killing
when it comes to george floyd that looks
a lot less like a racist killing to me
just on the facts of the matter when it
came to jacob lake that didn't look like
an act of police brutality at all
that looked like jacob blake resisting
arrest with a knife in his hand every
situation is different because the facts
matter in every situation
if you are talking about philando
castile which is an unjustified police
killing
that is a very very different story than
the story
of eric garner or even the story of of
trayvon martin
all these stories have different fact
patterns there are differential level
levels of guilt and we as human beings
are called upon to evaluate the fact
patterns in each of these circumstances
but i fear that as a culture we've moved
beyond fact
i fear that as a culture we have decided
that facts no longer matter all that
matters is people's self-definition
and their personal feelings there's a
sentence from a story in the new york
times that i talked about at length last
week that i think really sums up where
we are as a country
right the sentence was in the story
about smith college where it turns out
that there was a black woman who alleged
that a janitor and an a college
administrator and a cafeteria worker who
was utterly uninvolved
had combined in order to perpetrate a
racist act against her she was eating in
a dormitory
and they came and they told her to leave
and she said that this was racism there
was a full investigation none of that
was true
and the new york times had this
unbelievable statement
right the new york times had this
incredible sentence and i think it sums
up
pretty much everything you need to know
about the country right now quote
the story highlights the tensions
between a student's deeply felt sense of
personal truth
and the facts that are at odds with it
now normally in real life
we would say that they're a fact and
then there's opinion they're fact
and then there are lies they're facts
and then there's the spin but
in the world that we now inhabit there
are two competing versions of reality
right there is the reality that is your
deeply felt sense of personal truth your
identification of the truth as it
appears to you
and then there are the objective facts
and it is not that facts should
outweigh your deeply felt sense of
personal truth
that's the two are in conflict and we
ought to give both sides a look
well here's the thing once you even do
that as a society once you decide that
the facts
are at the very best only on par with a
deeply felt sense of personal truth
namely your opinion
or your feelings or what lies you tell
yourself so you can sleep at night
once you do that you cannot have a
republic
a republic literally is rooted in the
idea that you and i can have a
conversation
about a common set of facts right facts
that exist outside of us
and that we have the capacity as human
beings to sympathize with one another
and even understand each other's
emotional states
on a basic level right not fully because
you can never fully understand somebody
else's
emotional state because you're not them
but
what you can do is at least understand
where they are coming from right
all of discussion all of conversation
all of a republic
all the republic is based on these basic
notions
we have now cut against all of those
basic notions because if i apply to if i
appeal to facts in a given situation
that in and of itself is considered
discriminatory
it is considered as though i am doing
something bad to you
i see this most clearly in the realm of
the transgenderism debate
in which somebody declares that they are
a member of the opposite sex and say
well the facts are against that because
you are not in fact a member of the
opposite sex and they say you are
infringing on my liberty
by citing facts stop your citation of
fact you are not allowed to cite facts
in fact you should be banned for citing
those facts that is a
perfect example of a society in which
your
identification your your notion of self
is deeply tied
into rejecting facts that are
objectively verifiable about the world
and once that happens you can't have a
conversation because we have now become
the tower of babel
right the tower of babel that story
where god basically
says to the people who are building a
tower together he says okay now you
speak a variety of different languages
what does it mean to speak a variety of
different languages it means we can't
understand one another
there's an active movement in this
country to make it so we can't
understand one another and that any
appeal
to a common language a common basis
in facts or stats or data that that is
bad
and wrong and infringing on my liberty
of self-identification
is it this is the sort of
deconstructionist movement at its root
the deconstructionist movement of
jacques dereda and michel foucault right
that deconstructionist movement
basically said that there are these
things called facts but
the priority that your society places on
facts
is different right they're different
societies and they treat facts in
different ways
and there's nothing inherently better
about the way that your society treats
facts
right an enlightenment society that
treats facts as paramount there's
nothing better about that than a
non-enlightenment society that doesn't
create
treat facts as paramount that creates
instead myths as paramount
but perhaps that's better and once you
get to the point where we can no longer
assume
that we as people care about facts more
than we care about opinion
then you you literally cannot have a
society anymore and that's what we're
seeing right now
right every trial turns into a battle of
narrative not a battle over the facts on
the ground this is what happened
in for example ferguson missouri where
the fact of that situation with michael
brown
became completely irrelevant it did not
matter that hands up don't shoot never
happened
millions of people around the country
marched holding up their hands and
saying hands up don't shoot
because it was symbolically true even if
it was factually false right there's
something aoc said
what does it even matter if my facts are
wrong so long as my morality is right
and the answer is yeah it matters an
awful lot it matters an awful awful lot
because we can't have a conversation
otherwise
if facts are merely a reflection of how
your society sees truth
then facts really have no claim that is
superior to any other claim
right this is why the left instead of
appealing
to fact the left very often appeals to
structures of power
right so how do you determine who wins
in a conversation if we can't appeal to
facts and decide
who is bringing facts to support their
case
and then decide the argument on that
basis then how do you determine who
ought to win and who ought to lose
well according to the left the answer is
the person who ought to win is the
person who has been victimized
systematically
the person who is the victim of
hierarchies of power is the person who
ought to have more credibility
this is why for example in that smith
college case you saw nicole hannah jones
ask what is the social class of the
black student that this entire piece
centers on what is the actual power
dynamic at play here
as though her lying about a janitor is
somehow justified if she was poorer than
the janitor
or if she had a different skin color
than the janitor because then her deeply
felt sense of personal truth would be
rooted in class or race hierarchies
and that means that you ought to be
given additional credibility even when
the facts cut directly against her
the reason i'm talking about all of this
is because i believe that this sense
of facts not mattering this sense that
we ought to instead
look into our own hearts not in anybody
else's heart because you can't right
look into your own heart for a
definition of the world and then
everybody else is just supposed to go
around
acknowledging your definition of the
world this ends republics and it is it
lies at the center of everything that is
happening in our culture right now
every single thing from math to
literature from
journalism to criminal law it's
underlying a sense of everything
facts are no longer of import i i've
long had this tagline facts don't care
about your feelings the reality is
that at this point we are now in a
completely reverse situation in the
united states where feelings don't care
about your facts
facts are irrelevant facts are a
secondary concern and in fact if your
facts conflicts with the feelings then
your facts ought to be thrown out
i'll give you some examples of this in
just one moment first
let's talk about something awkward you
ready erectile dysfunction yeah that was
awkward wasn't it well here's the thing
you don't want to talk about it well you
still have to go get the medication you
need for it i mean it's a medical
problem it's not just going to go away
on its own because you don't feel like
talking about it well with roman you get
a free online evaluation and
ongoing care for ed all from the comfort
and privacy of your home
a us licensed healthcare professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it ships
to you free with two day shipping the
whole process is straightforward and
discreet
getting started is really easy just go
to getroman.com
ben complete an online visit take care
of your ed without leaving your home
complete that online visit today
connect with a healthcare professional
get it taken care of a lot of people
have a lot of medical problems that they
tend to ignore just because
it's uncomfortable to talk to a doctor
about it here's the thing get roman
makes it
easy and quick and discreet and
inexpensive so what exactly are you
waiting for just get
an annoying problem solved go to
getroman.com right now you get 15
off your first month it's time to take
care of that ed remember get started
today you save 15 bucks on your first
order of the
treatment at getroman.com ben
alrighty in just a second we'll get to
some examples of how the facts no longer
matter how a basis in logic and reason
no longer matters
here's the thing this ties into a
broader thing that we're doing here at
daily wire there are a lot of narratives
around hot topic issues
it's hard to keep track of all the
newest bs narratives the left is pushing
at any given day
right now obviously the left is pushing
the idea that men are women and women
are men for example it is difficult to
respond to these arguments because the
standards are constantly shifting
trying to argue with people on the left
very often feels like trying to nail
jello to the wall
and honestly the only thing you can do
is create a solid argument of your own
that is based in fact and based in
research and based in the data
that can be pretty time consuming well
we're doing it for you this is why i've
launched a new show it is called
debunked it's a new show i'm hosting
every friday the point of the series
is to provide you with a breakdown of
popular fallacies pushed by the
political left
i've done the research i know the data
i've done the work for you i walk it
through in 15 minutes or less on a
different topic every single week last
friday's episode covered minimum wage
i'm sure you keep hearing this argument
that a minimum wage will give you a
living wage it's a living wage what
liberal activists and politicians won't
acknowledge
is that the minimum wage actually
results in more unemployment so the
actual minimum wage is
zero dollars we talk about all the stats
in this week's episode of debunked
debunked is available exclusively and
only to dailywire members head on over
to dailywire.com
subscribe use code debunked to get 25
off your new membership that is code
debunked
go watch the minimum wage episode stay
tuned we have a new debunked
episode coming out this friday you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so let's talk about some
examples where the facts don't matter so
the perfect example
of an area where facts do matter and
where there are correct answers
is math right math is a very easy one we
should all be able to agree literally
the two plus two equals four
this should be something very very easy
well john mcquarter who is a
black professor of linguistics very
famous in his field
he has a piece over at sub stack titled
is it racist to expect black kids to do
math for real
he says there is a document getting
around called dismantling racism and
mathematics instruction
a guide put together by a group of
educators it has a black boy on the
cover
the idea is to show us how our racial
reckoning of light ought to change
how we expose black kids to math i
suppose the council is also intended for
kids of other types of melanin but this
is in essence a document that could be
called
math for blackheads the latest is that
state-level policymakers in oregon are
especially intrigued by this document
there is all reason to suppose that its
influence will spread more widely
this is to be resisted as this lovely
pamphlet is teaching us that it is
racist to expect black kids to master
the precision of math to
wit its message penned by people who
consider themselves as some of the most
morally advanced souls in the history of
the human species
is one that strom thurmond would happily
have taken a swig of whiskey to
of course the authors have it that quote
the framework for deconstructing racism
and mathematics
offers essential characteristics of
anti-racist math educators and critical
approaches to dismantling white
supremacy
in math classrooms by visualizing the
toxic characteristics of white supremacy
culture
okay well that is a lot of jargon
whenever
the left talks about deconstructionism
and why facts don't matter they use all
this jargon right they're talking about
hierarchies of power
and anti-racism by anti-racism they mean
disrupting those quote unquote
hierarchies of power
dismantling white supremacy is code for
we don't like things and therefore we're
just gonna say that they're white
supremacist
translated says john mcquarter this
means that math as we have known it is
racism
that's a rich claim if correct it is of
earth shattering urgency but is it
correct
let's see how it holds up now part of
anti-racist math teaching where it's
john mcquarter
is to teach about black mathematicians
or say air facts
such as that the traditional yoruba
approach to numbers use base 20.
no one would object to these things nor
to the idea that we teach students of
color about the career and financial
opportunities in math and stem fields
but 96 of people reading this kind of
thing will be thinking yeah but what
about the math
and there's nothing white supremacist in
that question the substance of a serious
proposal about teaching math
will be well teaching how to do math
itself not it's history and sociology
for example one one idea in this
fascicle is that the black students
learn how math has hurt people
but it's no slam dunk little kids need
to be taught this wouldn't this affect a
child's attitude toward mastering the
skills
more to the point is that this entire
document is focused on an idea that
making black kids be precise
is immoral the document pays lip service
otherwise claiming at one point to seek
to teach rich
thoughtful complex mathematics and
rather often the word praxis is used but
the thrust of the pamphlet is that one
a focus on getting the right answer is
perfectionism and
either or thinking two the idea that
teachers are teachers and students are
learners
is wrong three to think of it as a
problem that the expectations you have
of students are not met
is racist four to teach math in a linear
fashion with skills taught in sequence
is racist
five to value procedural fluency i.e
knowing how to do fractions and long
division
over quote-unquote conceptual knowledge
is racist that is black kids are
brilliant to know what math is trying to
do
to know what it's all about rather than
actually trying to do the math
just as many of us read about what
physics or astrophysics accomplishes
without ever intending to master the
math
that led to the conclusions six to
require students to show their work is
racist
and seven requiring students to raise
their hand before speaking can quote
reinforce paternalism and power hoarding
you may wonder if this is a cartoon says
john mcquarter but no this is real this
is actually what this document tells us
again and again
to this trust this document is not to be
against social justice but against
racism
now the point that mcquarter is making
is a very real one
we have seen that this this polarized
atomistic thinking
about ourselves as individuals that our
self-definition matters a lot more our
feelings matter a lot more
than learning objective skills or
looking at the data or trying to figure
out true answers
that that has deep ramifications for
every area of our society
and it's just sort of glossed over
because here's the thing
most people don't look at the deep
substratum of thought here the deep
substrata of thought
when it comes to all the stuff that we
are hearing about the vocabulary as i
call it
the vocabulary is just a bunch of words
that we are taught to mimic so we can be
part of the
upper class right i mean that's really
what it is that's what college is all
about these days it's why you see people
put
their pronouns in their twitter profiles
like i know you're a dude you don't need
to put he him
i know you're a chick you don't need to
put she her right if you're transgender
then maybe you will have a preferred
pronoun but the fact that you have a
bunch of people who are cisgender
putting pronouns in their profiles
is just a way of coding that you are a
member of this new upper crust elite who
speak the vocabulary and that's all that
matters
and americans want to be part of that
upper crust elite because americans have
always wanted to be part
of the new upper crust elite they've
wanted to be part of the new ruling
class it used to be that if you wanted
to be a member of the new ruling class
in the united states
what you would do is you would work
super hard and you dress really well
like above your station right you'd wear
a suit to the office
and you would try and get a nice wrist
watch and you would learn to help
you'd learn the word of the day and you
would try to get a good education
all right that was the way that you
demonstrated that you were a member of
the new ruling class
and more has changed more race change
and so you see now that to be a member
of the new ruling class means to
actually dress down right if you're mark
cuban then you wear jeans and a t-shirt
or if you're mark zuckerberg you wear a
hoodie
there are certain things that change but
the best way to become a part of the new
ruling class these days is to speak the
vocabulary it is just
the shave and a haircut two bits of
entry into the secret societies i've
said before
right when it comes to the use of these
terms it is not about understanding the
terms
most of the terminology does have a deep
academic background that is complete bs
but people don't have to know that and
they don't have to buy into it this is
why if you ask americans you believe
america is systemically racist
nobody understands what the term
systemically racist means
because that is a term that originated
in the centers of academia
it has actual content but it has been
robbed of its content for purposes of
polling
all you know is that if you don't say
that america is systemically racist then
you will be labeled a racist and you can
never be part of the new ruling class
right that is why this sort of
vocabulary is used
this is why it is now dear gore for
prominent people to talk about how they
are embarrassed to be a member
uh to be a white person for example so
john brennan
who seriously ought to be in jail i mean
he lied to the senate openly lies in the
senate but john brennan is still
considered
a person worth listening to he was on
msnbc and he just throws out a comment
like this right he says he's embarrassed
to be a white male
why i mean seriously why i don't
understand why should you be embarrassed
of your skin color
i don't think whatever your skin color
you should be embarrassed of your skin
color it's bizarre
okay but this is now considered a way
into by saying that you're embarrassed
to be a white male you can actually be
super proud of yourself
being a white male who says he's
embarrassed to be a white male so here's
john brennan former cia director
saying this nonsense speaking the
vocabulary
i'm increasingly embarrassed to be a
white male these days
like what i see my other white male
saying but it just shows that with the
ex with very few exceptions like
mitt romney liz cheney adam kinzinger
there are
so few republicans in congress who value
truth
honesty okay all his rest of his take on
the republican party doesn't matter at
all
the the fact that nicole wallace you
know and everybody who's a white lady
is saying that that is laughing when he
says he's embarrassed to be a white male
question why why and that's ridiculous
even if a white person did something bad
why exactly would that embarrass you to
be a white male
that's like saying that every black
person should be embarrassed because
there are some black criminals that's
ridiculous
why would you why that has something to
do with you you're an individual
but again it's about speaking the
vocabulary and if you don't speak
the vocabulary then you can lose your
job you could have been a member of the
new ruling class one second ago but if
you don't speak the vocabulary then
you're out
which is what happened to donald mcneil
over at the new york times he has now
released this this
long four-part essay explaining why he
was fired from the new york times you'll
remember
donald mcneil was the lead coveted
reporter at the new york times he was
nominated for
a pulitzer this year and he was ousted
from the new york times
for the great crime of having several
years ago gone on a trip to peru
where somebody asked him about the use
of the n-word by a 12-year-old girl
and he says well in what context was she
using that and he said the word and he
lost his job over that
well he was forced out he was forced out
by the editors at the new york times
because he had quote unquote lost the
newsroom
first of all i don't even know how you
lose the newsroom who gives a crap with
the newsroom things
seriously you're the new york times
you're the leading newspaper in america
you give a crap with the quote-unquote
newsroom things about your lead reporter
on covid in the middle of a pandemic
but according to the washington free
beacon dean baquette the
the public the executive editor of the
paper said i know you're not a racist
but encouraged him to resign anyway
because he had quote unquote lost in the
newsroom but cat said we're not firing
you we're asking you to consider
resigning
although mcneal technically resigned his
own volition he was under intense
pressure to do so
when the star science reporter asked for
details about the allegations piquette
was silent
mcniel said it felt like an attempt to
intimidate me
apparently the new york times union was
unwilling to defend mcneil the union was
quote deeply split over my case
he decided he needed his own lawyer the
the reason for all of this
of course is because he didn't speak the
vocabulary he said some things that were
in politics and if you say things that
are in politic
meaning they violate the precepts of the
woke
they violate the precept that facts
matter and the data matters then
like that entire incident was not about
him using the n-word the entire incident
was about him asking for specifics
you're not allowed to ask for specifics
because specifics provide clarity
generalities provide confusion
and room to wiggle right now all of
politics is about this
if you ask for specifics you are seen as
bad you are seen as wrong
you are seen as racist if you ask for
specifics you are seen as rebutting
somebody's deeply felt sense of personal
truth
and this is it's confusing stuff you can
violate
the strictures of the moment at any
point right twitch hilariously found
this out yesterday so twitch the the
streaming service
they received backlash from both
liberals and conservatives after
referring to women's history month as
wmx
history month w-o-m-x-n history month
and now nobody with a brain has ever
referred to women as
w-o-m-x-n but they were trying to make
it that women were different than
than woe men it's like so i married an
actual
axe murderer women whoa man
they basically then the trans community
came out and said this is terrible
because some women are men
he said it was transphobic it's just
it's hilarious
it's hilarious like it's it's pretty
spectacular
that the that the woke can't even get it
straight but that's the whole point
and in the end that's the entire point
and everybody everybody is on the
cancellation block
and if you don't cancel it the the best
path to joining the woke by the way is
to cancel yourself preemptively
and this is precisely what is happening
to dr seuss so
dr seuss's books are classics of
children's literature he's the greatest
children's author
for kids who are under the age of seven
of all time it is not close i read
doctors whose books to my kids
pretty much every day okay but according
to a virginia school district
dr seuss's birthday can no longer be
touted on read across america day
because a study said the author's work
is quote filled with orientalism
anti-blackness and white supremacy now
i grew up reading dr seuss books you
grew up reading dr seuss books everybody
grew up reading dr seuss books did it
make you more racist to read a dr seuss
book did ever even occur to you
that race was an element of dr seuss
books until i just said this one second
ago
of course not because no one no one is
actually outraged about this
there is no there are no human beings
who read dr seuss books and are actually
angry at them
all of this is just about signaling it's
about setting new standards
hoops for people to jump through and if
you ask for
any sort of context that provides
whether
the book is racist whether it is whether
it is racist
for to read if i ran the zoo because
there are people
of asiatic appearance in the book if i
ran the zoo
if you even ask that that in even the
question is racist
if you say okay well you know he drew
that in 1940
and let's just say that it was
insensitive in 1940 has any child read
this
in the last 20 30 40 years and come away
with a bad impression
of people from japan because they read a
doctor's who's book
to ask that question is to be the
problem because now you are asking for
evidence of a claim
that is by nature a claim that is rooted
solely in feelings
so how did the dr seuss foundation
respond to this not by defending their
guy
of course not instead the the
official organization that controls the
legacy of dr seuss said it will no
longer sell
six of the author's children's books
over racist and insensitive depictions
including
his very first major book and to think
that i saw it on mulberry street i can't
even remember what is supposed to be
racist and to think that i saw it on
military street
if i ran the zoo and magilla gets pool
by the way
i own all of them you should buy them
today they're great for your kids
the the notion that this is that
he perpetuated jewish stereotypes as
financially stingy
and he and that all of this appears in
his books the study published in 2019
examined 50 books by dr seuss found 43
out of the 45 characters of color have
quote characteristics aligning with the
definition of orientalism
unbelievable unbelievable it's just
it's all insanity but again to to call
for a
an end to the insanity is to excise
yourself
from the community of the new ruling
class and that is what all of this is
about in the end
there's only one way to fight back
against people who have declared
themselves to be at the top of the
ruling class and that's to say
you don't get to rule us end of story we
ignore you
you're stupid and we're not paying
attention to any of this nonsense ever
ever again but here's the thing the
biden administration is bought into this
stuff hook landing synchro so here's the
thing
the biden administration being members
of the new ruling class
and joe biden being an old white corrupt
politician has decided that
he he speaks the vocabulary too and it's
very important that he speak the
vocabulary because what the left has
basically done
is they've decided that by banding
together identity politics
and socialistic thinking they can craft
enough of a working majority to cram
through
their actual political agenda right to
go back to the original thesis of
today's show
it's all about politics it is all about
power and getting things done
it's about the authoritarian cram down
of certain policies
basically they're a bunch of people who
don't really buy into the vocabulary
who have decided they're going to make
common cause with people who do buy into
the vocabulary and a bunch of people
who actually believe in the inequity is
inequality argument
who have decided that they will make
common cause with the socialistic wing
of the democratic party
in order to cobble together a new
coalition of the ascendant
now you can see this actually pretty
well in bernie sanders if you look back
at bernie sanders original
presidential campaign in 2016 he didn't
speak about race nearly at all it was
all about how
all the problems in our society can be
laid at the root of the capitalistic
system and if you just get more
socialist it solves everything
then over the course of the next few
years something interesting happened to
the bernie sanders campaign
he was told that it was not racially
sensitive to speak only in terms of
class
now bernie sanders is basically economy
right i mean his perspective on
life is rooted in marxist fundamental
lies about class conflict and how all of
human
life is driven by this class conflict
everything he says is driven by that
and so if you believe that everything at
root is about class conflict it's not at
root about racial conflict right
the black working man and the white
working man have more in common than the
white working man
and the and the white rich man or the
black working man and the black rich man
it's about class it's not about race
but bernie sanders was told that this
was racially insensitive and so
he decided to make common cause with the
woke and start pushing as many woke
policies as he could get his hands on
and this was
rich small what has happened with the
democratic party writ large
this was the magic of barack obama right
is what obama did as president
i know that we have this picture of
barack obama as the barack obama was
this wonderful unifying figure
that is a figure put forth by the media
it is a lie barack obama of 2004 was not
the same as barack obama
2010. in 2004 barack obama was saying
there are no black americans there are
no white americans
we're all just americans there's no red
america no blue america
it's just america by 2010 barack obama
was breaking down americans into their
identity groups
so that he could specifically appeal to
members of those identity groups
to create a coalition is the reason why
he actually shrank
his number of votes between 2008 and
2012 but it was enough to get him by
mitt romney
so the merger between identity politics
and
typical sort of democratic party
politics has been ongoing and joe biden
is the culmination of that
which is how you end up with a machine
politician like joe biden and that's
what he is
as for a machine typical corrupt old
white politician
who suddenly become the face and voice
of the racial reparations movement
according to one of joe biden's top
advisors
he is going to start acting now to
address reparations to black americans
speaking to axios on hbo in an interview
set to air on monday white house senior
adviser cedric richmond discussed
efforts targeted to helping minority
communities
richmond said they're not waiting on
congress said we don't want to wait on a
study we're going to start acting now
we have to start breaking down systemic
racism and barriers that have held
people of color back and especially
african americans
we have to do that stuff now right
that's the vocabulary
and we're going to specifically appeal
on the basis of race and suggest that
all inequality is inequity
and joe biden has decided that equity is
the byword of his administration
so for example he says that we are going
to start talking about free college
tuition to historically black colleges
and universities
if you start talking about free
community college in title one and all
these things i think you're well on your
way
now let's be real about this if you're
talking about free college
the reality is that the great imbalance
in our society is the number of people
going to college between people who are
black and white
the number of people who are white going
to college by percentage is
significantly higher the number of
people
going to college were black that's not
because of lack of affirmative action
programs or benefits programs
or scholarship programs all of those
exist in plenty
right the real problem is the failure of
lower education
the failure of the public school system
so what is this it's a typical
democratic policy smuggled in under the
guise of the vocabulary
it's a typical democratic policy
position that is now being smuggled in
under the guise of doing racial justice
you call it reparations and then you can
push forward the idea that you are
speaking the vocabulary and you can
build your coalition
on the back of all of this and so
this is the new pitch this is the biden
administration pitch use the word equity
to cram down all the typical democratic
policy proposals
and claim that anybody who disagrees
with you is a racist because here's the
thing joe biden can't claim
that anybody who disagrees with him is a
racist it's bizarre that dude is whiter
than the back of this piece of paper i'm
holding up right now
i mean if in a whiteness competition i
come in a distant second to joe biden it
is not close
joe biden is a super white dude and yet
because he's using the language of
quote-unquote equity
and the language of anti-racism to push
for typical policy proposals the idea
becomes now
that it is white supremacy to oppose joe
biden's policy positions an old white
politician
one of the whitest people in america and
so
that gives him enormous ability to push
for these positions
while calling all of his opponents
racist which is again bizarre barack
obama could do it because he could just
say people who hate me are racist
and while it was a lie he could at least
pretend it was true because
obviously at least the factual basis of
him being a black person was right
joe biden not a black person still
making the same exact claims
so when you merge the democratic
coalitional ideal with the
racial ideal and all of it becomes about
those systems of power
right not about fact not about the
success of the policies about the
systems of power
you can get away with nearly anything
and joe biden knows this so what is he
doing he's pushing all of his typical
policies but all of it's going to be
based
on racial politics according to the
daily wire
ryan savannah reporting the biden
administration is reportedly considering
scheduling a controversial vote
on a gun control bill in the next couple
of weeks
well i mean of course he is because he's
always wanted a gun control bill
a report by punch bowl news which was
founded by former political reporter
said
house speaker nancy pelosi and other
house democrats were focused on turning
their attention to other issues the
biden administration
has on its agenda including gun control
after passing this giant
quote-unquote coveted relief package
which is really not a coveted relief
package
at all some of these controversial votes
would require universal background
checks on gun sales which of course
would create a giant gun registry
another bill would close the so-called
charleston loophole which allows gun
purchases to proceed
if the background check isn't completed
in three business days you can hold
these things up
interminably of course
and um essentially he's calling for a
ban on semi-automatic firearms i mean
that is what
when he says banning assault weapons
there's no definition to all of this so
this is you know typical democratic
policy being pushed under the guise
of equity other typical democratic
of equity is immigration policy so joe
biden has basically decided to open the
borders wide and we all know this
and joe biden has decided he's not going
to enforce immigration law he's going to
go right back
to not enforcing immigration law he is
attempting to kill agreements whereby
people have to wait in mexico in order
to see if they ought to be granted
asylum in the united states
instead biden just wants to release them
into the interior of the united states
and meanwhile he's trotting out his own
members of the government to just lie
about it so he's got the department of
homeland security secretary
alejandro mayorkas saying there is no
crisis at the border this is just a lie
there are about 8 000 unaccompanied
minors at the border that is the highest
number that we've had in
many many years that is indeed we're at
97 capacity
at the borders which is why we're now
reopening all the bad old trump
facilities right but it's not a crisis
it's not a crisis because joe biden says
it's not a crisis
here's alejandro mayorkas can you
believe that right now there's a crisis
at the border i think that the uh the
answer is no
i think there is a challenge at the
border that we are managing
and we have our resources dedicated to
to managing it one of your predecessors
j johnson he said that a thousand
illegal border crossings a day
constitutes
a crisis that it overwhelms the system
we're at between three and four thousand
now
according to cdp officials so how is
this not a crisis
um i have explained that quite clearly i
um
uh we are challenged at the border oh
well if you say it's a challenge not a
crisis that's totally fine and
if you say it's a challenge not a crisis
see a crisis would require you to
actually do something to stem
the tide of illegal immigration but
here's the thing for purposes of equity
the biden administration has no interest
in stemming the tide of illegal
immigration
in fact they are now openly saying well
you know it's kind of awkward for us
right now so if you just like hold off
on the illegal immigration for seven
minutes that'd be awesome
but you know in the end we're kind of
okay with it here's ellen this is the
the director of homeland security the
secretary of homeland security
alejandro marquez saying we're not
saying don't come to illegal immigrants
we're just saying don't come right now
guys we're a little overwhelmed
i don't have a particular timeline but
all i can do is communicate
both to the american public and to the
individual seeking protection
that we are working around the clock
seven days a week
to make that time frame as short as
possible but they need to wait
but they need to wait with a particular
goal in mind we are not saying
don't come we are saying don't come now
because we will be able to deliver a
safe and orderly process to them as
quickly as possible i mean i'm sorry
that's
crazy that's crazy we know that the vast
majority of people who are arriving on
america's southern border are not
legally claiming asylum
we know this okay that is just a reality
the vast majority of people who arrive
on the border
are not claiming political asylum in its
typical definition
an economic asylum is not a thing
because economic asylum just means
everybody gets in because america has a
really strong economy
and when he says we we mean just don't
come right now what he's really saying
is just come on
you know it's fine just come everybody
knows this including democratic
representatives
one democratic representative named
vincent gonzalez democrat of texas he
says this immigration policy is
absolutely catastrophic
again this is a democrat from texas
saying that the current administration
policy
makes no sense my concern
at this in the recent weeks in my
district migrants who made it across
the border who uh even passed the line
of mpps who are five thousand
uh folks that are that have been waiting
for two years across the border
made it across the rio grande valley
were processed and released
if that is the message that we send to
central america and around the world i
can assure you it won't be long before
we have
tens of thousands of people showing up
to our border and it will be
catastrophic
for our party for our country for my
region for my district
uh in the middle of a pandemic in an
area where we've lost over 3 000 people
in my small
congressional district okay i mean that
that is just the reality
that it's just the reality but it all
ties into the vocabulary again it all
ties into the idea
that if you can tie everything into race
if you object to this it must be because
you object to
america getting more brown or something
which is absurd
i've said 1 000 times i do not care
about the race of americans all i care
about is the ideology philosophy
and decency of americans that's all i
care about but
not so on the left because again it's
not about the fact
it's about the narrative and and when it
comes to the narrative
fact very often stand in the way of good
narrative alrighty we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content coming up soon the matt wall
show airing at 1 30 pm eastern be sure
to check it out over at dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's high events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show